لدينا قدر كبير جدا من التعاون
في مجال العلاقات الدولية
زيوت الجربل المذابة سكينر ديسمبريست
والحزن ليلى دي ليج عن العقول لأجل
مي سو sk نحن الاختناق
نحن هنا أيضًا نطور بنشاط
اتصالات الوزارة
الشؤون الخارجية ومن خلال قلبي
الدفاع girek تنفس مغلي الموز
ريكس العتاد من صالون زجاج إلى فلوروم وما بعدها
الشتلات
لك المريخ إلى حد كبير
المجال العسكري التقني مثل الجربر
تفوت ما زالت تان
مجموعة ضخمة من الأسئلة
علينا مناقشة أو تحرير دي
فوندو على طول لوحة بموجه الصوت سيدي وليام سوف الغوص تريد
نراكم متجرنا هناك بالفعل آخر
جزء مهم من تعاوننا
هو بالضبط في حقيقة أننا مع
معا نواصل القتال
الجماعات الإرهابية التي
يهدد يهددنا
أظهرت لي المنطقة ملائمة للنقل
هذا ينطبق بشكل خاص على الخطوات التي نقوم بها
قد اتخذت بالفعل توجيه الائتمان و
سنتخذ إجراءات في هذا الاتجاه
يوم المناجم مع الرموز في جميع أنحاء الجهة الخلفية
بلوك داندا تشغيل رامازوتي يو وأنا
أعتقد أن اجتماعنا اليوم
اجتماع مجلس التعاون الأعلى
المستوى له أهمية كبيرة في هذا الصدد
هي التجارة 15 في المائة من الإجمالي
60 مليار ولاية لامبريكين
راحة
متصيدون مهنة متنوع مطوية و gelecek
zil mmz جرامي الروح لدينا
جدا